good afternoon everyone my name is sten
vermund
i'm proud to serve as the dean of the
yale school of public health and i'm
delighted to welcome you to the global
health
conversation series
sponsored by the yale institute for
global health
this series is a venue for our community
to learn from and connect with
innovative leaders in global health
in addition to yigh we're indebted to
the george herbert walker jr lecture in
international studies at the whitney and
betty mcmillan center for international
and area studies at yale for
co-sponsoring the series including
today's event so it's a pleasure to be
with you today and to introduce our
speaker
each year since 1988
on december 2nd yesterday
we've commemorated world aids day i
remember vividly the very first one
i had started my job at the nih on that
day
and
this highlighted urgent the urgent need
and the inequalities that drive hiv and
aids and other pandemics around the
world
the theme for this year's world aids day
is end inequalities
end aids
and pandemics
so 40 years plus since the first aids
cases were reported
hiv still threatens the world
today the world is off track from
delivering on the shared commitment
uh to um
end aids by 2030 not because of a lack
of knowledge or tools to beat aids but
because of structural inequalities that
obstruct proven solutions to hiv
prevention and treatment
as well as being central to ending aids
tackling inequalities will advance the
human rights of key populations and
people who are living with hiv
make societies better prepared to beat
covet 19 and other pandemics
and support economic recovery and
stability
fulfilling the promise to tackle
inequalities will save millions of lives
and will benefit society in myriad of
ways
to celebrate or commemorate world aids
day and discuss some of these important
issues
we are so pleased to have with us today
dr anjali ashrakar
the acting u.s global aids coordinator
and special representative for global
health diplomacy in the department of
state
dr atrakar has dedicated her career as a
public servant to global hiv aids women
and girls health and global public
health development after working in
india and later with unicef headquarters
on adolescent health she accepted
position with uscdc in 20 in 2001 where
she focused on integrated adolescent
health
programs and services
since 2003 dr atrakar has been working
on pepfar's global hiv aids efforts
in 2005 she went to south africa to help
local governments plan and implement a
rapid assessment of drug use and sexual
hiv risk patterns among injecting and
non-injecting drug users and sex workers
in three cities durbin praetoria and
cape town
after serving as country officer for cdc
she became the senior public health
manager supporting cross-cutting
system-wide sustainability activities
and strategies
in cdc's division of global hiv aids in
2011 she joined the u.s department of
state and helped lead the
conceptualization and development of
saving mothers giving life
as well as facilitating the
implementation of this important program
for those of you who don't know about it
it was a public and private partnership
that impacted maternal and neonatal
health
in the context of hiv service delivery
dr ochracar holds a doctorate in public
health from a very good program uh the
university of north carolina chapel hill
we love that program we love our friends
at unc but most importantly
she has her master of public health from
the yale school of public health so
welcome dr osher carr back to your alma
mater
thank you so much dr vermund and and to
the entire yale community uh
and the yale university but specifically
a huge thank you to the yale institute
of global health i'm just so privileged
to be here uh with you commemorating
world aids day that occurred yesterday
i have a few slides to cover and to
share the experience um and to provide
an update of on where we are globally um
if that's okay so if i could start with
uh the
presentation to really walk you through
commemorating world aids day and talking
specifically about the impact that we've
had as a globe through the president's
emergency plan for aids relief
on the next slide please
i always start every presentation by
talking about how critical
and instrumental the unwavering
bipartisan congressional and
presidential leadership of pepfar has
been
we are 18 years
in this fight through pepfar which again
started with president george w bush in
2003.
each subsequent president has picked up
the mantle and really led
um and and supported this program with
an incredible amount of of effort we've
also enjoyed bipartisan support across
10 congresses over the nearly two
decades of the of the program's life
most recently with the current
administration the biden harris
administration i can't even begin to
tell you how incredible their support
has been and i'm pleased
to be able to talk with you in the next
couple of slides here about how
president biden
really leaned in uh particularly on this
recent world aids day
yesterday but but really how the
administration has been leaning in and
building upon the the successes of all
the previous administrations um uh since
so on the next slide
yesterday president biden hosted an
incredible event at the white house
where the domestic and global hiv
community was brought together
private sector universities
congress uh faith-based organizations
activists it was an extraordinary in the
u.s government it was an extraordinary
uh coalition of people
of passion that has been built over the
past 40 years in this fight
as a part of his remarks he announced
pepfar's latest global results which are
nothing short of extraordinary
he announced that together through
pepfar with countries and communities
we've saved more than 20 million lives
we've prevented millions of hiv
infections and helped at least 20
countries bring their hiv epidemics
under control this is extraordinary
particularly in the face of covid19 but
just full stop without a vaccine or cure
to have nearly 19 million people
women men and children on life-saving
treatment for example is incredible to
have prevented nearly 28 million
or to have conducted nearly 28 million
circumcisions in order to prevent hiv
infections among men and young boys
again nothing short of extraordinary
next slide please
we have over the years supported
population-based
surveillance
studies household surveillance studies
to really uh validate results that we're
seeing in countries
here we're seeing a
somewhat of a busy slide but what's
important to note is
how far countries have come in terms of
achieving their 90 90 90 sustainable
development goals this is tracking the
number of uh the percentage of plh
people living with hiv that are aware of
their status and those that are aware of
their status that are on life-saving
treatment and then those that are on
treatment that are virally suppressed so
you can see the bars in terms of the um
the the positive the the percent
positive um the percent on treatment and
then
those that are virally suppressed in red
blue and gray respectively
what's important also to note on this
slide is the the percentage in orange
which which is the community viral
suppression
it's absolutely incredible when you look
particularly at the left side of this
graph here to see botswana at 93 98 98
with 89 community viral suppression
malawi a very resource limited country
at 88 98 and 97 percent with 84 viral
suppression at the community level just
extraordinary how far countries have
come together um uh with communities as
a result of americans
leadership and generosity in really uh
working
on this fight together next slide
it's important also to note that even in
the midst of covid19
that pepfar has continued to
not only maintain
the number of people that we have on
treatment but we've continued to grow
the number of people that we have on
treatment despite the peaks and covid19
transmission so on this slide
across in color you can see the number
of waves of covid uh 19 cases
per million people in a select number of
countries around the globe and in red
you could see the number of individuals
that have continued and grown on
life-saving
art
next slide
i also wanted to show here that we have
had challenges as a result of of covid19
these data
show
our circumcision performance
over time over over a few year period
you could see where covid in quarter
three of fiscal year 20 really impacted
uh the program where the pro where the
services dropped dramatically this was
intentional we had made sure that we
were doing everything that we could at
the height of covid19 to really protect
the people that we were serving uh to
keep them out of the way
of covid uh of infection from kovid
19.
what we are seeing over time however is
that with adaptation to the program
we've been able to rebound and
stabilize the program over over the
quarters and and this is quarter three
data but shows that 70 percent
achievement toward our annual target um
again comp this is complementary to
where we were in previous fiscal year so
again we've been able to rebound and
this is really
because of incredible work that has
happened at the country level by
extraordinary people and partners that
we're working with and real-time
adaptation to the program next slide
and here just gives you a sense of of
some of the prevention services uh and
pre-exposure prophylaxis for adolescent
girls and young women similarly you can
see a dip in our prevention services for
which for adolescent girls and young
women on the left side of the graph but
a but a stark increase after we've we
started to really adapt the program and
use different modalities uh to
to uh implement prevention activities
and with pre-exposure prophylaxis here
you see sort of a stabilization um
through covid19 when when the impact
really came but the important thing here
is a real steep incline um
through kovid this shows us um some of
the preferences that the people we serve
have and so prep is something that we're
really actively
trying to scale up not just for
adolescent girls and young women but but
all populations next slide
over the while while we have been a
categorical
hiv-focused program
and we've been working to sustain
through covet 19 sustain those hiv gains
we have been pivoting and adapting to
really respond in the wake of covid19
we often talk about the pepfar platform
and and what does that what does that
mean
well what we've learned over time is
that
all of the effort that we've been able
to do in partnership with countries
communities and partners
over the years
on hiv services and delivering hiv
services has effectively created a care
delivery platform that has yes been
instrumental to hiv but has also
recently been instrumental to responding
to covid19
we have
thousands of u.s government teams
from the various agencies cdc usaid
peace corps the department of defense
all of the very nih all the various
health and human services operating
divisions and others we have local
strong local implementing partners and
and trusted relationships with partner
governments
all in 55 countries around the globe
these relationships these people these
partners together with the incredible
health system
infrastructure
investments that we have made over the
course of pepfar's life which is which
has really
you know been expressed as over 15
billion dollars but but
tangibly resulted in over 3 000
laboratories just on the continent of
africa that have been established and
networked including reference
laboratories over
over 70 000 healthcare facilities in
which we work with direct access to
clients as well as granular data at all
of these facilities
nearly 300 000 health care workers that
we have
trained on hiv
doctors nurses community health workers
epidemiologists laboratories etc and a
robust
commodity supply chain that is in place
it is this system this platform that has
been critical um to respond to covid19
since kovid really hit you know the
globe in early 2020 we've been
adapting our program and leveraging this
platform to support covid19 screening
diagnostics infection prevention and
control
demand generation for vaccination
as well as administration of vaccines
themselves i think secretary blinken
said it best when he was recently in
africa um
on a couple of weeks ago where he said
pepfar has saved millions of lives
brought the world to the edge of the
first aids-free generation and
transformed public health infrastructure
where the investments we made years ago
in labs and clinics formed the backbone
of this nation's covid response and he
was specifically talking about nigeria
but this is true across the board next
slide
and the president himself yesterday
during the world's eight world aids day
uh ceremony
said it again
with his words by strengthening
countries abilities to fight aids we've
also improved our collective ability to
fight other diseases and we couldn't
agree more next slide
so as i noted since early
march i would say or late february 2020
we have been adapting the pepfar program
and providing technical guidance on how
we can lean in to leverage the pepfar
supported health systems and
infrastructure and as i noted to do
everything from
covid19
screening and diagnostics and now all
the way to uh vaccination
next slide
one of the things that we did at the
outset when covid19 first hit was was
really make sure we can protect the hiv
gains
we we did a number of things to ensure
that we were focused on person-centered
care to protect the populations most at
risk for poor covid19 infection outcomes
as well so things that we implemented in
in with urgency
was you know making sure that
people on treatment um had we had
absolute connection with them
uh tracking methodology platforms in
place so that we can ensure that their
treatment was uninterrupted
we rolled out multi-month dispensing in
a matter of weeks we have been this is
something that we have been
at um with country governments for years
but it wasn't until covid19 that country
governments realize the important to the
importance to move quickly to ensure
three and six months of drugs for stable
um clients this was a way to decompress
facilities and also make sure that we
were reducing the potential exposure of
covet 19 to
people living with hiv
we decentralized drug delivery we went
we went closest to home closest to the
communities where the people we serve
are we used virtual platforms
telemedicine and other ways to
communicate with beneficiaries of our
programs a lot of the prevention
programming
that we had traditionally done in person
in group settings was not possible
during covid19 and so we were able to
adapt and and institute virtual
platforms quickly and i can't say enough
about the about empowering communities
and how important communities and local
partners have been
in this fight but particularly through
covid19
community-led monitoring to ensure
quality services and leveraging
community health workers
has been absolutely critical next slide
this is just an example wanted to show
some data of the rapid increase in the
percentage of people living with hiv
that were on um art comparing
fiscal year 20 quarter one data to
fiscal year 21 quarter three data and
these data reflect um though the
multi-month dispensing that i noted
earlier you can see when you look at the
left side of the graph compared to the
right side of the graph
the increase
in three to six months of multi of drugs
for stable clients so again country by
country you can see a real increase in
shift from um from
uh
you know toward i should say uh more
months of
of drugs and this has been a saving
grace in the wake of covid19 next slide
we've been so grateful that the congress
uh and this president
appropriated additional resources
specifically for us to respond to
covid19
we received 250 million dollars
to prevent and mitigate covid19 impacts
on pepfar programs and beneficiaries and
i guess i should start by saying i
didn't say this earlier pepfar
is a tremendous effort
implemented in 55 countries but over the
past 18 years reflects a hundred billion
dollars
of american taxpayer dollars in this
global in this
enormous global hiv response
so
but that was focused on hiv specifically
receiving 250 million dollars
to really focus in on utilizing the
system and the platform we have in place
to really respond to covid19 has been
critical
so we
were pleased to be able to program these
resources quickly so that we could
continue
to utilize the platform to help respond
specifically to covid19 next slide
i wanted to provide a couple of country
examples and these are hot off the press
as of 7 a.m this morning when we had a
global call home with all of the 55
countries
to really talk about how we can and
should continue to lean in
and utilize the pepfar supported
platform to help in in uh covet
vaccination in particular
particularly with the um with the recent
variant and the need for us to to really
mobilize quickly
this is an example from south africa
with their ongoing covid19 vaccination
support and these are just examples of
ways that we are bringing both of these
efforts together the hiv response and
the kovid 19 response to be
nimble and to be
impactful uh as as kovid 19 continues to
rage on the continent so we're doing
everything here from supporting the
healthcare workforce that is that is
doing everything from data capturing to
vaccination and arms as i said earlier
to procuring equipment and protective
equipment
vaccine consumables freezers ways to
support vaccine delivery
transport and logistics support you know
data systems are absolutely critical
including um
including support
supporting the national department of
health
and working together so so again these
are ways that that we are bringing these
efforts together on the next slide
and here's an example from zambia
really important and critical work that
they've been able to do
focusing in on
pepfar supported facilities where
um that are focused for delivering uh
antiretrovirals um to people living with
hiv
so a real intentional focus on
vaccinating people living with hiv in
existing art clinics and so
what they have seen in a matter of weeks
really is a focused effort in these art
clinics and high burden um
areas in lusaka in a week we're able to
vaccinate a thousand people living with
hiv again
you know and that that mushroomed um
where other facilities across
now over 500 facilities across 10 across
all 10 provinces in zambia are rolling
out uh this this program
uh
really pushing uh covet 19 vaccination
for people living with hiv as well as
family members and others that accompany
them the ministry of health was so um
thrilled about this that they issued a
circular which is there's a picture here
in in late august they issued a circular
um expanding this policy and this effort
across all 10 provinces so we're really
excited about this and looking forward
um looking forward to what might be able
to be achieved by bringing these efforts
together next slide
and again they used the opportunity of
world aids day yesterday to really bring
together a vaccination a covet 19
vaccination surge with world aids day
activities so bringing a a a really high
level uh
push from the government of of zambia
together with the u.s government to see
what might be possible by the end of
this fiscal year or sorry by the end of
this calendar year by bringing um a real
push for covid19 vaccination next slide
there are of course challenges and
opportunities to sustaining epidemic
control of hiv and as i noted and showed
in the population-based surveys there
are countries that are getting that new
infections are continuing to drive down
and all-cause mortality or israel is is
being driven down as well countries are
beginning to control their epidemics but
there are challenges including
inequities that continue to persist
among adolescent girls and young women
key populations and children and these
are areas where we are trying to double
down
covet 19 of course continues to persist
and this is something that we need to
continue to proactively get ahead of to
ensure that we're not just
protecting
the gains in hiv but continuing to
advance and accelerate those gains in
the midst of covid19
and there are real opportunities to
tackle some of these inequities by
working differently across sectors
by really bringing a refreshed
perspective to how we're disaggregating
uh data across younger and more specific
populations for example
to drive where our investments go and
then again utilizing the platform in
different ways um to help respond for
the future next slide
there are some elements about um there
are some elements about
what a sustained response to
uh epidemic control of hiv might look
like and it really has to do with
equitable health services and solutions
um
across the board but but there are
elements that include um a whole of
domestic approach between the
governments the partner governments and
communities enabling policy and
programmatic environments that that
remain
barriers to services
but that having these in place are
absolutely critical sufficient
functional capacity to maintain these
programs and these services
financial
sustainability is is essential as well
domestic resource mobilization
and then integrating hiv services into
the broader public and private care
delivery systems to really ensure that
when we have a country at epidemic
control of hiv that that we are really
ensuring that that
that control which is a very um dynamic
place remains uh in control and so
ensuring that a robust public health
response to monitor and track
existing and emerging threats becomes
even more critical as does quality
assurance next slide
just a couple of slides on on
on finances hiv investments by funder
this slide shows by country on the rest
on the right side of the graph
the percent contribution from pepfar the
us government in blue the global fund
which the us is a big contributor to and
then partner governments in gray and we
continue to work seamlessly
across partner governments the global
fund and and with the us government to
make sure that our investments and and
services complement one another next
slide
but we continue to be concerned because
of covid19 when we look at the projected
gross domestic product growth versus hiv
prevalence rate as seen on this graph
you can see economic problems from covit
across the board but are pervasive and
worse in countries with high hiv
prevalence as noted within the red dots
on the right side of the graph here next
slide
one approach that we've been utilizing
is
is sustaining delivery of hiv services
through local and community partners
this has been an approach to
sustainability that we have been uh
trying to employ for a number of years
now and we're seeing significant uh
gains and movement in the in the right
direction here where we're really
working to make sure that funding is
going directly to local and community
partners themselves as you can see in
the graph across the country some
countries have 80
over 80
percent of their funding going to local
partners
and it's not just the funding it's
ensuring that the local capacity and
capabilities of these of these partners
exist to implement services um
uh in the respective countries next
slide please
just a couple of final slides here just
to note that we're really bringing an
equity lens uh to the effort um to
complement our work on accountability
transparency and impact to really make
sure we're closing those gaps that i
noted earlier and on the next slide
and i'll stop here which is we've been
working with many of you and others
across the globe
to to develop a pepfar strategy for the
next five years to help guide our
efforts moving forward and these really
relate to accomplishing the mission
finishing what we started
building enduring capabilities as i
noted earlier how critical health
systems enabling environments and local
partners are and finally building
lasting collaborations
next slide
and with that i'll just say thank you
and turn it back over to you saad
hi um
so um
dean wellman was
you know
started the event on our host of the
event on behalf of uh yale institute for
global health unfortunately he's in
transit in the dominican republic
um so while he is connected i will be
filling in for him for the question
answer sessions
um and uh you know we'd be happy to uh
sort of uh field questions from the
audience as well as uh you know a few
other questions that that we have been
thinking about so first of all thank you
for a really nice talk and a
comprehensive
overview of uh the progress of that far
and and you know what are some of the
things uh by far has been doing lately
uh and those of you who don't know me
i'm sad omar i'm the director of yale
institute for global health
yeah so
you know the first question actually
came from
our
participants our audience
and and and i think it's it's very
timely in the context of uh the overall
environment
because you know there was very strong
bipartisan support for pepfar
when um
it was first launched
do you still see that support
thanks so much sad i i have to say you
know it you're right when pepfar was
first launched there was incredible
bipartisan support
um you know across
across the u.s government with president
george w bush who was extraordinary
in in launching such a such an
incredible effort but also across the
congress from republicans to democrats
you know there's something magnificent
about the hiv fight it brings all
walks of life together
and what we've seen over the years in
the past 18 years and what i noted in my
in my presentation
is that
every year since
every administration since and every
change of congress since they have
equally come in
and brought
you know stood on the other's uh
shoulders and really
continued to bring
the highest level of
congressional and presidential
bipartisan leadership and as i noted you
know
most recently with president biden
it hasn't it wasn't just with world aids
day um where where the
enormous support and leadership of the
global response
was displayed
since day one of this administration
uh president biden
and and the administration has really
put their arm have put their arms around
this issue
supporting
all of us
um and and the effort and the fight um
in every way that we have come together
in the multilateral space um
there was the un high level meeting this
summer that happens every five years
where the administration
showed full support but all the way to
the way the budget looks to the way um
you know again the political leadership
as well so you know they've also
recently um
announced that the us will host the next
replenishment of the global fund uh to
really make sure that we are advancing
our efforts for hiv tb
and malaria around the globe uh through
our multilateral efforts as well so this
is so the bipartisan support has been
critical it's been maintained and grown
um over over the years and we're
incredibly grateful for that
well that's wonderful uh so the second
question comes actually from
uh dean verman um
and he
raised an interesting point that it's
obviously
really good to see that pepfar has
aided um in the covert 19 response and
especially the in-country infrastructure
has been repurposed utilized and by the
way not for the first time for a major
public health emergency
uh can you comment on other expansion of
mission as with the
non-communicable diseases and and people
have sort of strong opinions
on that
you know one is that you know it's it's
a no-brainer uh that you have built that
infrastructure and there's this new not
new but um
this uh
emerging and important issue of
non-communicable disease but on the
other hand uh there's this instinct a
few people have is to preserve the
capacity
uh for for a purpose that it was created
so we'd love to hear your thoughts about
uh you know expansion to and ncds
yeah no thank you for that important
question and you know as we as
you're right in that in that you know
the pepfar platform hasn't only been
utilized for covid19 we've you know
there have been so many ways over the
years whether it's
other infectious you know areas like um
like ebola or you know when h1n1 sars
mers you know
so many other uh areas but we've also
uh been utilizing uh the platform to
respond to
tb
to respond to um you know cervical
cancer uh and so so those are examples
of how we've how we've
expanded
to help really
move in in the direction of
non-communicable diseases
i think the question is a really good
one
because
is a very delicate dance that we have to
do in order to make sure that we
don't
don't dilute our efforts in hiv
while
we do what we know is the
smart thing to do which is to utilize
capacity that exists
to to to help respond and so that's why
we've been very deliberate and
careful about how we've been
uh responding to covid19 for example you
know tying it to
um
looking at the data and making sure that
we are doing everything to
preserve the hiv gains while we've been
able to expand as we've needed to
i think um you know i think we would be
look we're we haven't finished the fight
yet and that's why i mentioned
um you know there are gaps that that
persist and we've got to close those
gaps for hiv
but we've gotta we we can't also ignore
the fact that there is this incredible
system that that exists and whether we
like it or not
countries realize and see the power
of the systems and capabilities that are
in place and and see that the need to be
able to bring synergy together
so
you know
my thought is
we need all ships to rise we need to
utilize that platform that exists
because starting from scratch doesn't
make sense
but we've got to be able to do it in a
very careful and considerate way so that
um
the outcomes that we've been able to um
to achieve together on hiv
uh don't you know uh
don't backslide
yeah and we got a sort of a related
question saying that obviously we
definitely don't want to lose the
progress that we have all made
so far and diversify the hiv aids
funding sources to the forward 19
pandemic
so you know as someone who sort of has
run this kind of a program of this
magnitude
do you think there's a need for a new
font or
or some sort of
um
you know another entity or or a resource
uh for covert 19 and future pandemics
because
we don't have to have uh
uh a pie of of a fixed size we can
increase
um
the size of the pie itself public health
is extremely
cost efficient uh we get really high
returns on investments but but do you
think there is a value in a separate
fund for pandemics like government 19
or something of that sort
so you know the the global health
architecture and what the future looks
like is a hot topic of of conversation
as i'm sure you're very well aware of
and immersed in
and and
you know i think and part of the reason
i showed
what was possible with 250 million
dollars
of the american rescue plan funds
was that
with with a relatively small amount of
money
250 million dollars
in our six billion dollar a year program
how much we've been able to do
because we have systems and capacity and
infrastructure in place
so so
you know i guess i guess
you know
setting up a fund
um
specifically
for pandemic preparedness and response
you know there's certainly a different
skills
there's a broader skill set that needs
to be brought to bear that is not solely
in the hiv
sphere
but but the time
the time that might be involved to do
something like that
when we should be
when we're in the midst of two pandemics
right now hiv and covid19 and and being
able to respond quickly
um that's only possible with
infrastructure that is on the ground and
capacity on the ground right now to
mobilize quickly and so i guess that's
the long way of saying
i think a fund i think
i think a separate fund um you know
again we'll see where the conversation
of global health architecture falls um
but but there's definitely something to
be said for building on
investments that have already been made
uh because that's a fast
uh
you know uh efficient way to work
oh yeah though i think and of course
we'll have to think about
the horizontal versus vertical
nature of programs uh you know obviously
uh there are trade-offs there and you
know on both sides or sort of the
diagonal nature of some of some of these
programs that are sort of hybrid between
vertical and horizontal programs um so
do you think um
it is
now is the time for a pepfar um
level
effort specifically so not necessarily
pepfar but a vaccine distribution effort
that is of that scope so some of us
call for it like in march
of 2020
um
so so yes we have discussed that there
is uh this uh you know
the issues of a separate fund but it's
more long-term etc
but but more immediately do we need
something of that magnitude for this
problem that we have right now where uh
we need an end-to-end solution
yeah i know thank you for that question
it's it's such an important one
you know and and
again in in the same way that that
president biden has really expressed
tremendous support of the global hiv
response we were so
um pleased and i hope many of you
participated in or
have been tracking
the the global summit on covid19 that
occurred um around the un uh general
assembly uh in the fall
where the president you know
really tried to
mobilize uh the world
to to step up um to step to step up on
on vaccination across the globe you know
putting bold targets out there
um you know of 70 percent you know
trying to get uh the coverage rate to 70
across countries and what that could
look like and how how we as a globe not
just you know not just the united states
but we as a globe need to sort of
collectively move in this way so
i'm
and we've since had um
some uh follow-up ministerials to really
try and urge uh you know the vaccine
delivery and administration
you know
the u.s has been donating
you know
hundreds of millions of of
uh vaccine one of the concerns that that
we have um and i'm just you know giving
an example uh from the
the african uh context
is there's a lot of supply
actually right now
and in many of the countries one of the
concerns
is
is
much of what we we face here as well
hesitancy you know actually getting uh
vaccination administered um in a timely
way we're seeing some waste of of some
of the vaccines so so these are these
are questions that are also being uh
considered
so um
you know look you you have a particular
strength as a leader because your own
background
includes a lot of work
in the field itself
and i hope we sort of nurtured some of
those values and
attitudes here at yale
uh at an early part in your career
but what what what do you think how
has that informed
your leadership style
as you have
sort of
risen to sort of leadership positions
within the program itself and and is
there anything any insight that you can
share with our students from that
perspective
someone from the field of someone who
has gotten their their hands dirty that
someone who hasn't been dropped into an
agency um as an appointee with with a
lot of other assets but not necessarily
field experience but you you have direct
field experience
and any insights
well i i so appreciate that question and
and
speaking directly to the students at
yale um
so so
on a personal level let me just tell you
a little bit about why
uh
the
number one why i chose yale and why
yale and the approach the comprehensive
approach of the public health program
the global health program in particular
was so instrumental in forming
um
forming me
uh in in my career in my service um that
i've since been doing 20 years
20 plus years since
what what is extraordinary what was
extraordinary then 20 plus years ago
when i was a student there
uh as a master student and and what drew
me in and what i know is still
consistent at yale
is the comprehensive multi-sectoral
approach of the global health
effort
when i first started it it was brand new
it was it was a newer you know field a
newer uh part of of the program but what
i loved about it was
how
uh we
at the time had uh professors and
opportunities from the medical school
from the business school from the you
know there was there was a
multi-sectoral approach um that was
absolutely critical
one of the one of the experiences that
really changed my world um was
what many i don't know if this is still
part of the curriculum at yale but but
the summer between first and second year
of the um of the masters program when
there is some sort of internship type
work
that's when i went to unicef to start um
to start that you know to do my to do my
internship and and that turned into a
love of of of this work that then turned
into
going to the field that then turned into
time in
countries and that
began um
my my love for um for this work and for
the service uh that i've done as a
career public servant
as you noted i'm not a political i you
know i i
have been in the government um and and
experienced
um some of the real struggles and issues
um
that that people face
in communities
all around the
globe and and to be a part of something
no matter how big or small something
that is really making an impact on their
lives is the most
um is the greatest honor of my lifetime
and and so it's just it really did start
with that approach
that yale um
uh instilled in me
of service of of experiencing the field
and and translating
um
science and research into real public
health impact so um
yeah
so so that's wonderful to hear and you'd
be happy to know
that uh the yale institute for global
health has actually formalized
uh um
a global health leadership
fellows program that is open to any
trainee and student at yale from
undergrad to actual post-docs research
and clinical
and everyone in between including
graduate students etc that has a formal
free departure
component then we place them in
global health agencies um like unicef as
as you did that save the children and
many others
and then we'll expand to when to
ministries of health
as well this is in addition to field
placement programs this has a specific
focus on leadership and service uh
particularly public service um and so so
that program has expanded and it's good
to know that you know these kinds of
investments pay off so this particular
program is new and expanded but but the
earlier efforts i have i think i can say
confidently has had a high return on
investment
um and so
in terms of uh you know going back to
you know
a little bit
um
you know a focus on
partnerships that you mentioned
um
specifically
you know thinking about how
faith-based organizations can be
leveraged
to help with hiv aids you know stigma
prevention and care
and
and what are the the new frontiers i
know that pepfar has
from the beginning uh collaborated with
faith-based organizations but what are
uh
the new
directions in that kind of of
partnerships and what are some of the
lessons because look other sectors other
entities will have to partner with
face-based entities and organizations
from the grassroots to the global level
and some lessons from pemfar would be
very
sort of
would be very useful for those sectors
as well
yeah i know it's such a um
it's such an important um question and
an important um
sector that is that is critical to the
response you know i mentioned earlier in
my remarks that
that um
there's something extraordinary about
the the
the hiv fight and that it brings
so
so much diversity so many sectors
together
everything from
and part of part of that is the
bipartisan support from congress you
know
just as many republicans as democrats
love this program you know um we have
the
most conservative um
uh religious groups um that that have
have equal you know have have critical
roles to play
um in in the response as the most
liberal
you know uh
ngos or or
lgbtqi plus organizations you know our
advocacy groups are so broad um so so
again there's something
beautiful about about the hiv the global
hiv fight that has brought so many
people together faith-based
organizations as you noted sad
faith-based organizations have been
critical to this response from the very
outset
and and
they and you know i talked a little bit
about local community organizations and
i include faith-based organizations in
that broader you know in that broader uh
subset
faith-based groups have been there in
these countries before we were there you
know they um they have access to people
in ways that
that we absolutely need to talk about
some very
um
sensitive issues like stigma and
discrimination today i mentioned you
know we we were on um
on with all of the country offices and
we were talking specifically about
involving faith-based organizations
in covid vaccination for people living
with hiv because there's a real
hesitancy
among pregnant women living with hiv
and their hesitancy about covid next
vaccine um
uh and and the impact that it might have
on their on their child and so you know
the conversation was around well how do
we involve faith-based organizations
that are trusted um uh
you know institutions in many of these
countries and that have um influence in
in in so many different ways so again i
think they
they have played they continue to play
and they will always be needed in in the
response
wonderful um and the last question is um
uh you know many and i i think i know
who asked this question from our
audience uh someone with a sort of a
significant student role
the question is many in our audience are
students that aspire to work in global
health
what is your advice to these students as
they consider
what to do after yale i know you have
alluded to some of that stuff
but but i think would love to end on
that note
so what to do after after yale
um well the good news is is you're
getting a really incredible experience
while you're at yale and i would
encourage you to seize all of these
opportunities including that new um
or the fellowship that you were
describing
the new the way you've institutionalized
that field experience because that's
really exciting
you know i would encourage you to be
open and flexible
you know part of the
it's it's amazing how
um
you know oftentimes as i reflect back
now often times it there's never a
direct route to where you're headed um
when it comes to to your career
but there are experiences that if you're
open to to seizing
if you're open to seizing
you it could it could move you in a way
that that really compels you
um to focus
um and that's what happened for me there
was a um
there was a incredible opportunity
it was a fellowship at cdc
that was specifically focused on
integrating services across the
and this was domestic but across
the um the education and health sectors
and that intrigued me because of a lot
of the work that we were doing in the
global health space of bringing
different sectors together and that's
that's one of the things i learned at
unicef when i did my internship there
and that
that intrigued me and so i applied and
got that fellowship and that set me on a
course
that
in terms of integrating across sectors
and integrating services for adolescent
uh for adolescents and that has then
evolved um and and you know again i just
being flexible and and focused on the
mission on and and on service that that
is com that you're compelled by and
inspired by i think really helps move
forward but but also reached out to
reach out to people that you know
um
that are in various places uh as well
because they're we are always looking
for good people uh to join our teams
wonderful
thank you and um as you alluded to that
uh by far
and and i think if i can say so by far
reflects the best of america
um
bipartisan
um with empathy with adequate resources
bringing in
good solid technical expertise but at
the end of the day partnering with
communities and countries
and working as true partners rather than
parachuting in solutions
and having long-term commitment so i
hope
um
pepfar remains
that example but doesn't remain the
the isolate one of the no i wouldn't say
rare but one of the few examples of uh
this country making
solid investments in global health uh
that results in this a win-win situation
and i'm sure it's been a privilege for
you as well i hope uh that to lead this
incredible program
in the recent past so so thanks for
coming and uh thanks for your words and
engaging us
in this conversation
thank you so much and and thank you for
the opportunity and um it really has
been
a a privilege of a lifetime to be to be
a part of something
uh that that
has really been a movement around the
globe um so
i i am just so grateful to have uh been
with you today and shared uh how some of
my roots uh there from yale have helped
um contribute to
to who i am today and the service um
the service uh that i've been so
privileged to provide on the on behalf
of uh the the american people
so thank you very much
yeah thank you thanks for coming and
thank you for all of us
uh all of you who joined us today we
look forward to seeing you at the next
event of yga conversation series in
early
2022 uh we have a pretty exciting
program brewing uh
for you uh and happy holidays
thank you